saviez vous qu'un des plus denses et
commerce de limoges et le commerce de la
viande le progrès mais aujourd'hui à la
disposition des consommateurs les moyens
les plus modernes et se livre au service
de la viande offre les produits les plus
variés ce système devancé d'ailleurs
multipliés dans les centres urbains
cependant un quartier de limoges est
resté fidèle à sa tradition depuis dix
siècles un des plus anciens commerces de
la ville si ce n'est le premier fut
celui de la viande ce commerce avait
lieu exclusivement dans une rue bien
précise de limoges la rue torte appelé
par la suite
rue de la boucherie l'ailé boucher du
quartier s'étaient dès le moyen âge ou
péan corporation
monsieur thibault nous nous trouvons
dans un des plus anciens quartiers de la
ville c'est le quartier la wii la
boucherie quelle est l'origine de la
corporation des bouchers
la corporation des bouchers à l'âge 930
environ et a été constamment dans la rue
jusqu'à ces dernières années de quoi se
compose est à l'origine
la corporation des bouchers de quelques
familles qui comprenait l'intégralité de
la bouche vive de la ville de limoges
et maintenant et maintenant c'est une
corporation qui a presque disparu
et quelles étaient les traditions du sud
alors cette compris cette corporation
avait des traditions tout à fait
spéciale elle était de quelques familles
celle qui exerçait le métier et c'était
tout à fait artisanale
chaque famille avait un chef de famille
qui était le père ou à son défaut la
verve qui reprenait la tête de la
famille et toute la famille travaillait
dans la même dans la même boutique
tandis les corporations et est une
entreprise familiale
c'était un environnement familial et
dans cette corporation par contre il y
avait quelques fois des employés qui
étaient à ce moment-là a pris par la
famille et qui vivent exactement comme
la famille vivait à la table familiale
le quartier de la boucherie a conservé
son style médiéval par les petites
ruelles et ses vieilles maisons
on
certaines possèdent encore le grenier à
claire-voie ou les pots été séchés oui
c'était le quartier le plus animé de la
ville
cette animation se perdent jour en jour
et dans chaque boutique
c'est avec un peu de nostalgie que l'on
évoque l'ambiance d'autrefois et
autrefois il y avait beaucoup de monde
la rue et enfin beaucoup de bousculades
déjà marchande et venez acheter de la
friperie la boucherie et qu'elle était
en train de préparer l'actuel et bien
tout à l'heure je fais que des glaces de
moutons et des joues et c'est comme ça
que vous prépariez de force one
on les fait sécher dans la cheminée et
puis on les mène à la norme hic dans les
fait cuire et les musées sont très
gourmands essayant de cette marchandise
et le giro qu'est ce que cette notion
bien le giro c'est du sang de moutons du
plasma tu sens
longtemps que l'on met dans un boyau et
que l'on fait cuire et comment ces frais
après avec du lard parce que
l'entreprise est ce que le commerce
d'êtres humains existent d'un patient
qui se faisait autrefois oui dans quelle
maison
d'autres se servent de gaz les conduire
au gaz c'est pas la même chose mais
enfin dans quelques maisons trois ou
quatre maisons encore dont se servent
d'eux comme d'anciens temps du feu de
cheminée et dansant reste que le
commerce et le même toit
1 c'est un peu plus qu'à nous bien vu
car dans le temps vous allez beaucoup
d'ouvriers des usines qui venaient
acheter de la tri soit des joues des
landes est il allé voir n'est ce pas il
allait manger dans un bistrot vous allez
voir mais maintenant tout perdu
parce qu'ici autre porte c'est surtout
du gros appris auprès du groupe et en
maintenant ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant c'est venu à 0 pour
quelles raisons
et bien parce que ça se fait le commerce
se faire valoir
le gros se fait à l'abattoir alors qu'on
n'a plus de raisons de venir dans la rue
de la boucherie postule gros ils vont à
l'abattoir
ici on n'a que l'on n'a que quelques
clients attitrés
il ya tellement de boucherie qui sont
hors de la vie lors de la rue de la
boucherie n'est ce pas ils ont tous dit
ce n'est pas tout alors ça ma cliente
est moins forte mais comment envisagez
vous l'avenir dans cette la boucherie
alors à zéro m ça va disparaître à huy
environ l'avis de la confrérie de
saintes aurélien est entièrement liée à
celle de la corporation des bouchers
limoges sainte aurélien deuxième évêque
de limoges après saint martial fut
choisi par les bouchers comme saint
patron
les reliques de sainte aurélien
somptueusement conservés dans cette
chapelle qui précisons le appartient à
la corporation des bouchers de limoges
la confrérie de saintes aurélien qui a
fêté son millénaire en octobre 1900
prend collabore avec la confrérie de
saint martial à certaines fêtes
religieuses en particulier les
ostensions septennale propre limousin la
confrérie a également un privilège dont
le président monsieur peine maison va
nous parler
elle participe pas toutes les sommités
religieuses de limoges et principalement
la grande famille de saint martial
on fait des ostensions cette taille à
fait vrai mais vous m'avez dit que le
confrérie recevait aussi les chefs
d'état lorsqu'il venait l'idée c'était
de passage à nous la joue cet examen
le roi henri iv
passage à 16,105 est soit disant ils
auraient accorder ce privilège à la caf
en s intéressant à la corporation des
bouchers dimanche
pourquoi soi disant toujours
le boucher de limoges on va te prêter de
l'argent pour moi de france mais ce
privilège
nous l'avons toujours puisque
j'ai reçu moi même le président auriol
en 1947 de tout dernièrement le général
de gaulle feuilles que les temps
modernes puisse maintenir ce lien
religieux unissant dans une même foi
tous les bouchers limoges réunis dans ce
quartier depuis des siècles